Programovací modely jsou základní specifikace, které definují
jak je software strukturován
a spouštěn – poskytují framework
pro vývojáře k vyjádření algoritmů
a organizaci kódu, přičemž často abstrahují nízkoúrovňové detaily
podkladového hardwaru nebo prostředí spouštění
různé modely se hodí pro různé typy problémů
a hardwarové architektury a nabízejí
různé úrovně abstrakce
a kontroly. V této kapitole
si projdeme kvantové a klasické programovací modely
a uvidíme, jak je můžeme kombinovat k vytváření algoritmů
ve vysokoúrovňovém prostředí
Začneme programovacím modelem
pro kvantový počítač. Jeden základní programovací model,
který zná skoro každý kvantový vývojář,
je kvantový circuit. Nebudeme zacházet
do detailů kvantových circuit,
protože k tomu máme spoustu skvělých zdrojů,
včetně přednášky od Joan Waters.
Jen zmíníme, že circuit se skládá z
sady linek zvaných dráty, které reprezentují qubit,
dále gate, které reprezentují operace na kvantových stavech,
a sady měření.
Dalším důležitým konceptem programovacího modelu
jsou
primitivy. Ty reprezentují nejčastější úlohy,
které uživatelé chtějí provést na kvantovém počítači.
V tuto chvíli jsou k dispozici dva primitivy:
Sampler a Estimator. Sampler ti umožňuje
vzorkovat stav připravený kvantovým circuit,
a Estimator ti umožňuje odhadnout očekávanou hodnotu
pozorovatelné veličiny pro systém ve stavu připraveném tvojím kvantovým
circuit. Posledním konceptem,
o kterém si v téhle sekci povíme,
je transpilace. Transpilace
je proces přepsání zadaného vstupního circuit
tak, aby odpovídal topologii konkrétního kvantového
zařízení
pro spouštění na hlučných kvantových počítačích.
Podobně jako klasické kompilátory
transpiler rutina postupně mění
strukturu circuit aplikováním sady průchodů.
Teď si povíme o klasických programovacích modelech.
Existuje mnoho programovacích modelů
pro klasické počítače,
ale v téhle kapitole se zaměříme na dva
nejoblíbenější: paralelní programování
a task workflow. Díky těmto dvěma modelům
v kombinaci s kvantovými programovacími modely
lze vyjádřit prakticky libovolný hybridní
kvantově-klasický workflow jakékoli složitosti.
Model paralelního programování
rozděluje program na podproblémy, které lze spustit
současně. Existují dvě hlavní paradigmata paralelního programování:
paralelismus se sdílenou pamětí a paralelismus s distribuovanou pamětí.
Pro naše účely se soustředíme na model distribuované paměti.
Model distribuované paměti
používá nezávislé procesy na oddělených jádrech
nebo uzlech, kde každý proces má vlastní paměť
a komunikace probíhá přes předávání zpráv. Existuje
několik konceptů, které je dobré znát.
Prvním je proces –
nezávislá instance programu
běžící na samostatném jádře.
Dále rank, což je jedinečný identifikátor procesu.
A pak existuje model SPMD –
Single Program Multiple Data –
což je abstrakční model
pro výpočty, kde je jedna instance programu
distribuována na více uzlů.
Zdrojový kód je tedy stejný,
ale data na těch uzlech jsou různá.
Model paralelního spouštění
funguje následovně:
jeden program se distribuuje na více uzlů
a spustí více paralelních procesů.
Řídící tok programu je určen rankem,
tedy identifikátorem procesu,
a komunikace probíhá
přes předávání zpráv.
Model programování task workflow
abstrahuje výpočet do grafu nebo DAGu,
kde každý uzel grafu je konkrétní task
nebo job a hrany reprezentují závislosti a pořadí.
Příklady najdeš v naší dokumentaci.
Sekvence, o které v kvantových výpočtech
neustále mluvíme – mapování, optimalizace,
spouštění a post-processing –
je vlastně model task workflow programování,
kde se všechny tasky provádějí jeden po
druhém v pipelině.
Ale s task workflow
nejsme omezeni na sekvenční pořadí spouštění
a můžeme spouštět tasky paralelně.
Každý task nebo workflow může být samostatný paralelní job
sám o sobě, takže můžeš
tyto modely kombinovat a popisovat algoritmy
jakékoli složitosti.
Zkusme teď aplikovat některé koncepty, které jsme se naučili,
na kód. Nejdřív zkusíme spustit jednoduché hello world
pomocí paradigmatu paralelního programování.
Budeme používat Open MPI,
což je implementace protokolu MPI,
který je standardem pro předávání zpráv
v paralelním programování.
Nejdřív potřebujeme mít náš program připravený.
Tady používáme mpi4py,
což jsou Python binding
pro MPI, a jak vidíš, používáme tu rank k rozhodování
o řídícím toku programu.
Podívejme se teď na náš odesílací skript.
Jak vidíš, budeme používat dva uzly –
jeden task na uzel v normální partition –
a spustíme náš program. Chvíli počkáme
a pak si zkontrolujeme výsledky našeho jobu.
Jak vidíš, máme výstupy logů našeho programu.
Použili jsme dva uzly a dva procesy,
které jsou identifikovány rankem,
jak vidíš tady ve výstupu –
rank nula a rank jedna, které slouží k rozhodování
o řídícím toku našeho programu.
Jak vidíš, proces rank nula odeslal
payload procesu rank jedna
a proces rank jedna ho přijal.
Teď si povíme i o task workflow.
Existují nástroje zvané systémy
pro správu workflow, které jsou speciálně navržené
ke spouštění složitých workflow.
Abychom tě nezahltili, budeme používat vestavěnou
funkci závislostí ve Slurmu
k sestavení těchto výpočetních skupin.
Nejdřív potřebujeme mít tasky workflow
připravené. Tady je stejný kód.
Výhoda toho, že máme každý z těchto tasků –
mapování, optimalizaci, spouštění,
post-processing – jako samostatné kroky,
spočívá v tom, že můžeme specifikovat jedinečné nároky na zdroje
pro každý task. Třeba mapování, optimalizace,
post-processing nepotřebují
přístup ke kvantovým zdrojům,
takže je můžeme spustit na klasické partition.
Ale task spouštění bude potřebovat
kvantové zdroje, takže ho spustíme na kvantové
partition.
Teď použijeme funkci závislostí k zřetězení tasků
do workflow.
Jak vidíš, pořád běží
náš sbatch příkaz s příznakem parsable,
který vrátí ID jobu,
a pak můžeme toto ID jobu předat
jako závislost dalším taskům
nebo jobům. Jak vidíš, spouštíme
joby ve workflow se závislostí.
Jakmile je celý workflow hotový, můžeme zkontrolovat výsledky.
A jak vidíš, máme zpátky naši očekávanou hodnotu.
A také si můžeme prohlédnout všechny
výsledky z každého kroku.
Které jsou taky tady.
A to je vše k sekci o programovacích modelech.
V další kapitole si budeme povídat o pokročilých
algoritmech.